So, I'm gonna
spend a little bit
over a half an hour just going
through a a quick
background of
how we've been
using storytelling
and metaphors to
promote knowledge
graphs. And, just to give you
a background, I work,
in a company where we have
literally hundreds
of different
business units.
And each of the business units
make their own decisions about
what new technology we use,
and what they use.
So we have to work
with them to,
explain these advanced
technologies.
And and what we're finding is
that if we can't explain it to
nontechnical people,
they're not interested.
So we're using a series
of stories for,
non programmers.
These are finance people,
marketing people,
health care executives to help
them understand the value of
these connected datasets.
So, the questions
that we'll try
to answer today is,
what is storytelling?
How does it help us explain
things to a nontechnical
audience?
The stories are really to
illustrate
the differences between,
connected knowledge graphs and
the traditional
relational databases.
And we're gonna talk a little
bit about some use cases,
and then we'll talk about how
we test these stories and how
do we promote the idea of
integrating AI with
these things.
So just to give you a quick
background here,
the way I approach
these things
is as a solution architect.
And, one of
the things I try to
introduce to
people is that our
job is to introduce
you to a series
of families of technologies,
and we are not
here to say that
any one technology will solve
all the problems.
But what we are
finding is that
there's a new
trend about using
graph databases or we call it
highly connected datasets to
help solve big
enterprise problems.
So, what is the role
of the solution
architect? The
idea here is that
if any business unit comes to
us and says, gee,
we need some help
with this problem.
We are going to come
up with a series
of ideas, and our,
goal is to be an unbiased,
matcher of their problems to
the solution sets.
We then take them
through a very
traditional process called
architecture trade off and
analysis method, where we,
look at the quality attributes
of what is important,
what are their requirements.
We look at our alternative
approaches and when
we do analysis.
And a lot of
the work I'm doing
is then how do we
fill in this box,
of the right things,
and when is it appropriate to
recommend canal
connected datasets,
through graph technologies?
So that's a lot of
what I blog about.
A lot of the topics is how do
we explain this to people.
Now one of the things that,
I have to mention is that,
I'm not the only person that's
doing this. Hillary Mason,
one of the most,
successful data scientists,
in her in her
conference keynote
in twenty eighteen,
she mentioned that metaphors
drive design decisions.
How we decide things is often
not the fact that
we really have
a deep understanding of how
these integrated circuits work
and how they
optimize queries,
But because we're
given a series
of stories to tell,
and it is our job to make sure
those stories
accurately reflect
the architecture and that we
create ways for
people to remember
those stories. Because most
important is when we're
not in the room,
what do people talk about?
And if they mention the right
stories and if they use those
appropriately, they'll they'll
we can guide them to
the right decision.
So just one of the things we
always start off
with is remember,
just just because a technology
is hot doesn't mean
it's appropriate
for everything.
And you can see that graph
databases are
clearly the hottest
technology, around,
and this is,
really, taken from DB engines
that harvest the web and find
everybody that's talking about
certain things.
And then notice that graph
technologies have really,
taken off in their
popularity.
The second thing to realize is
that with this
growing popularity,
we're not gonna
be forced to use
generic hardware.
We're seeing this
new generation
of things called
the hardware graph,
where we're getting custom
hardware to build
these things.
And this is a natural
progression.
Right? We started
out with these
things called data lakes,
the Hadoop ecosystems.
But we inter tried
to integrate
them together
with these things
called hubs. We realized that
connecting them and allowing
those to be queried
makes sense.
All of my blogging,
I'm on EKGs,
enterprise knowledge
graphs for
the last two years,
have really been helping you
guide yourself on the pathway
so you can get
to this hardware
accelerated graph.
And
the the hardware acceleration
is just astounding.
Just in the last
couple of months,
we've seen some incredible,
speed ups in
hardware execution.
So, what does this really mean
by hardware? Hardware,
today is optimized,
a lot of the processors to do
generic processing.
They're not
designed just to do
one thing and one thing well,
and that is
the pointer hopping
that we use in
graph traversal.
Having custom
integrated circuits,
that is optimized,
this is gonna give us a huge
boost in performance.
And this is not just about,
reducing instruction set.
This is also about
how we access
memory patterns.
So, the the big trend here is
to understand
the fact that in AI,
we've started out
at the ground
level of looking at images and
looking at sound,
and this is what we call very
dense data. Dense data is data
where our pixels
every pixel has
data in it, and we
load that into a GPU,
and it's it's very efficient
because it's using
all of the data
in memory.
In health care and a lot of
other things at
the upper level
of cognition, where we're not
just classifying things,
but we're trying to
make connections,
We have this problem called
the sparse matrix. Right?
So if we took all
of our patients
and put them in
one in each row
and then put a one
in every ICD
disease condition they have,
you'd get this huge
massive matrix,
but ninety nine
point nine nine
nine percent of
it is all zeros.
So we need ways to
efficiently manage,
data that has very
sparse data,
and that's how why graph
technologies are
a logical choice.
And I'm just gonna
give you three quick,
overviews of that,
of things that have
been happening.
One is the fact
that when a new
patient comes into our,
emergency room or clinic or or
urgent care, we wanna
ask the question,
have we seen a patient
like this before?
And of all those patients that
are the most similar,
take the hundred patients in
the world that are
most similar,
what is the care path that we
can suggest to get them better
the quickest? What
is the optimal
recommendations, and what are
their treatments?
And so this is
a very important
thing that we do not overnight
in a batch job,
but right when
the patient comes
into the room. And
what we realize
through this is
that we have to
understand the idea that there
are many things in knowledge
graphs that are
inherently serial,
where every task
that completes
can't start,
the next task until
that task is done.
We call those serial
graph algorithms.
And what we're trying to move
to this new era is
called parallel
graph, where we can instantly
take a new condition
and compare
it with literally hundreds of
millions of things in fifty
milliseconds,
and that's a much
different challenge than we've
seen in the past. Alright.
So, how do we how
have we done this?
We've done this by using,
standard parallel computation
such as an FPGA.
Xilinx is a very,
popular distributor of that,
and we've been able to hook up
our graph databases,
TigerGraph in this case.
We create a user
defined function.
We convert each
patient to thirty
two bit integers.
Those are called
patient embeddings.
Embeddings are
a really big trend.
And then we run
it through this
parallel hardware,
and it bang,
it comes out the top
most similar
patients in twenty
eight milliseconds.
So it shows you that we don't
have to be slaves
to the current
processors that are given us.
We can be very
creative at doing
these things. Another company
that's making great head head
ground headway is
a UK company,
Graphcore. Graphcore
has realized
that a lot of the performance
benchmarks that companies are
running in the past have been
only working on dense,
and what they're
doing is building
systems that work very,
very well on sparse matrix and
graph representation.
That's the name graph in there
in the name of the company.
Core processors,
massive amount of thread,
thirty five
thousand threads in
each one u, device,
and you can stack
those devices
to get a huge
amount of parallel
compute. And then
just, last month,
this incredible paper out of
Intel called the Intel, Puma,
unified memory architecture,
where they'll be
building custom
chips just focused on,
graph traversal.
So, their goal is
a one thousand
fold increase in performance,
and that's really a story that
has to be told.
Anytime you can
get three orders
of magnitude faster
performance,
we want people to
really remember
that that's gonna have a big
impact on our, enterprise
knowledge graph analytics.
So now the question is,
what are the right use cases?
So we're gonna
walk you through
some stories that talk about
the right use cases.
Performance is
obviously a big thing.
Flexibility is another thing.
And the one that's the hardest
for people to get their heads
around is this idea of using
graphs to
implement deterministic
rules and to
give recommendations
and nest nest next
best actions.
So, one of the things we found
is that in order
for our enterprise
knowledge graphs to work,
we do need
an executive sponsor.
This is often our
chief executive
officer that understands
the strategic
nature of real
time analytics.
We've also found that getting
our developers
on board is also
a critical step.
But I have to tell you,
after about three
months working
on graph databases,
developers usually never wanna
go back to the old
relational systems.
What we have the problem is is
in the middle.
And remember, when
you get a typical
million dollar IT
project running
these days, you typically need
to get seven different layers
of management to, make,
get consensus that, you know,
this is the right
direction to go.
If any one of these
people disagree,
they will block
your progress.
And so these
stories are really
designed for these
middle level
managers that are
not technical,
but really want to,
understand why they should be
doing this. So these,
retelling is
something that has
to be transmissible
through not
just one presentation,
but you need to
be able to give
this to teams and allow those
teams to then retell
these stories
to other teams
while you're not
in the room. That
means that you
have to use memory devices to
help them memory
remember the key facts.
The facts need to be graced on
based on the truth,
but our storytelling is really
designed for this
viral nature of,
getting people on board.
So, I'm gonna walk you through
four metaphors quickly here.
And these metaphors
are really about,
storytelling, in a fun
and creative way,
so that people will
remember this.
The most important
one and the one
that comes up
the most is called
the neighborhood walk.
And what this does
is this helps
people understand this idea of
index free, adjacency.
When two things in the real
world are connected,
make sure that there's a quick
way to hop between
those things.
So let's go through,
the neighborhood walk.
Let's say that you
live in a house
and you wanna
walk over to your
neighbor's house.
Well, how would you do that?
Well, you'd walk out
the front door.
You'd point to that
neighbor's house,
and you'd walk there.
And this is exactly
the way that
graph databases work.
Everything that is related to
other things have in
memory pointers.
Now we wanna
contrast that with
the traditional relational
databases that store atomic
units as rows in tables,
but they were
never designed to
join things
together as quickly
as a pointer hop.
They added that feature
on at the end,
when they took their
COBOL flat files,
and they said, well,
let's create some IDs,
and we'll compare all of those
IDs in memory. And then we'll
be able to traverse
these things
once all those IDs
are compared.
And every time
we run a query,
we have to recompare
those IDs.
Whereas graph is
not like that.
It's a thousand times faster,
and that typically means each
core processor can traverse
about two million edges per
second as long as those edges
fit in RAM. We'll talk about
that in a little bit.
So, this is the definition,
and I'm not even gonna read it
because nobody will
remember this.
It's too technical.
We need a story
that's compelling.
So when we talk about this
neighborhood walk,
we talk about how
quickly of in
thirty seconds,
you can walk over to
a neighbor's house,
And we can then model
that in a graph.
But let's compare this to how
you'd have to do
this if the story
was living in what we call
relational land.
Now in a relational land,
you're not allowed
to put a pointer
in memory if two
things are connected.
You are forced.
Imagine you walk out the front
door and there's a big
stop sign there,
and the stop sign says, stop.
You cannot go directly to your
neighbor's house.
You need to go
downtown to this
huge bureaucratic
building called
the central index.
And imagine, kind
of like a a big
government center with,
long lines like the DMV,
and you're gonna
be standing in
line for hours and
hours and hours.
And you're never gonna get to
the front until your your your
queue you get to
the front of the queue,
and then you're
gonna say, gee.
I I need to go to my
neighbor's house,
and they say,
what's the address?
And you have to
give it to them.
Now it's one two
three Main Street,
and they enter it into their
search index, and they
start searching.
And the more houses there are
in your town, the longer those
searches take. And
they finally say,
oh, okay. Here's the longitude
and latitude of that house,
and then you're permitted to
walk over to your
neighbor's house.
So what's
the difference between
these two? And the difference
is roughly
the difference between
a pointer hop and a join,
which is about
a thousand, fold.
And that means that it's gonna
take you about
eight and a half
hours to do this walk whenever
you're trying to
traverse relationships.
So this story
should be told in
a funny way, in
a humorous way,
in a way that's
gonna make people
remember. Remember,
everybody hates
standing in line
for hours and hours.
Remember the pain
and suffering
and do that. And if you can
evoke that emotion,
then you have a good chance of
getting people to remember and
tell this story.
Oh, do you do you
think we should
be waiting for three orders of
magnitude every
time we do look
at these relationships?
And if not, then they can tell
this story to
themselves. Alright.
So that's our first story,
never in luck. Second story is
what we call
the knowledge triangle.
And this isn't so
much as a story
as a way of thinking
of the guru
sitting on
the mountain top and
all the knowledge that has
accumulated in that wisdom,
is handled at
that top level of
knowledge. And as you go down
deeper and deeper
into the pyramid,
you're gonna get more binary
ones and zeros,
and you're gonna have to spend
a lot of time. So the question
we really want to ask in this
story is how do we
store knowledge?
What is knowledge?
How is it different
from the raw data?
Now if you study
these, AI textbooks,
here's a table
of contents from
the most popular
book in artificial
intelligence. You'll see that
a huge amount of their work is
on knowledge and reasoning.
How do we store
knowledge in a way
that we can traverse it?
How do we build ontologies and
taxonomies? How do we store
things in structured knowledge
representation
systems like SCAS?
So those are all
questions that,
AI has struggled
with in the past.
But now what we're doing is
we're starting to
see that instead
of storing data at this low
level binary code data,
which is typically what we see
in a data lake. Right?
There's no semantic
layer there.
That's just the ones and zeros
dumped from your operational
source systems.
What we're doing is when we
assemble that data into things
we understand, that's called
information, the people,
the places,
and things, the concepts,
we don't tie we don't really
make it usable until we tie
those patterns together.
And so, this is often called
the d I k w pyramid,
or we just call
it the knowledge
triangle because
we don't spend
a lot of time talking
about knowledge,
at the top. Wisdom
is really how
do you make store knowledge in
a way that's
transverbal between
systems? How do
you make a single
representation of the truth so
that all your
business units can
do that? It's it's
a really a higher
level of how do we
store knowledge
to make it accessible across
multiple systems.
So the challenge we have about
this story is that we have to
also make sure that it talks
about the productivity of our
people who are
analyzing this data.
And, if you take a look
at the typical,
customer satisfaction
of the data
lakes today, they're not very
happy because
each of them have
to write separate
ways to access
this data. We have hundreds of
data scientists,
where I work,
not thousands.
They each have
their own libraries
to make sense of this,
and they say eighty percent of
the time that they
spend is just
the data engineering,
getting all this data,
connecting it together
for each project.
Only about twenty percent of
their real work
is actually data
science, building
the models and
testing those models.
So what we're starting to see
now is that we are moving from
this idea of
the data swamp into
this highly rich
area of knowledge
graphs, and we're
gonna be using
AI to continuously
harvest this
low level data
for patterns and
connect those
things together.
And the idea then
is we'll then
get to the stage of
reusable wisdom.
So there's a couple other,
and I'm not gonna spend quite
as much time on these.
One is called the open
world assumption,
where we say that
anybody should
be able to add any
data at any time.
I should say that
we are borrowing
this term from
the semantic web
where they have a closed
and open world,
but we're really focusing on
the idea that
anybody should be
able to add new
data to the graph
at any time without breaking
existing queries.
And the idea here is
we want to often,
build either a fixed schema or
agnostic schema,
and there's
different trade offs
for doing that.
SQL databases all
have fixed schemas.
Some, graph databases are,
schema agnostic,
and some allow us
to do validation.
And we can use,
rules like shackle to validate
those data, optionally,
validating those
data on top of
our knowledge graphs.
So, the key thing
is in the past,
when we had these
relational databases,
we weren't allowed to add new
data to these things without
going through a long involved
approval process.
And the reason was that if we
change the structures,
all of those SQL
queries might break.
So we're trying to go to this
new world where
anybody can add
anything as long as that model
does in fact reflect truth,
reflects the real real world.
There's another
pattern we call
the Jenga tower.
And the Jenga tower says,
what is the stability of your
queries over time?
And the idea here
is that little
block at the bottom of this
tower is like a new attribute
that you want to add
to a relationship.
And anybody should be able to
add add that. But the problem
in the past is we had to often
refactor all of our code when
we wanted to make
a small change
in the data model.
So the real question is,
how do we change the way we
build things so that our our
query pools are stable?
And one of that things is that
we we have a focus
on data modeling.
We try to model
the world correctly,
the model of truth,
and we don't worry about
optimization of
a join anymore.
We focus on a single model of
the truth that
everybody can use.
So, why is this important?
In the past, we've done a lot
of research on
the stability of
SQL and Spark queries.
We found that as we
change the model,
we couldn't hold up.
And that's why,
LPG and labeled property graph
models really are taking off,
as one of the reason
that they're
taking off because
of the stability
of these systems. Okay.
So, that's kind of
some of the the
basic stories. I'm gonna take
you through a few
other ones because,
integration with,
a lot of the AI
systems are much,
more interest for people.
My blog has lot
of these other,
stories, and I'm not gonna,
go through them
too much because
loft often they're,
really focused on
a certain area.
But one of
the stories I wanna,
go through is this idea of
explainability
and why knowledge
graphs help us with
this explainability.
And here's the way
the story goes.
There's this bar,
in your neighborhood
called Deep
Learning Bar, and
they have this
deep learning bartender.
And the bartender
has a reputation
for recommending
really good drinks.
So you go into
the bar and you say,
hey. I I'd like
to have a drink.
And the bartender says, oh,
that's great. And he looks at
you up and down.
The robot says, from
the looks at you,
I would say that
you would like
a Guinness. And you say, wow.
That's amazing.
That's my favorite drink.
How did you know I'd
like a Guinness?
And the bartender looks
at you and says,
I have no idea. Right?
And that's the idea here.
You can recommend something,
but you can't explain it with
deep learning. Right?
We have these very,
very deep neural networks,
but they all are
abstract mathematics,
and they have no semantics.
They have no meaning
in the real world.
And that's the thing
that we can
bring together when we bring
the right marriage of
knowledge graphs,
where we use machine learning
to build these concepts and
the relationships and
their connections.
But when we make
a recommendation,
we can traverse those graphs.
We can traverse the concepts,
and we can build
an explainable
letter so that we can explain
to our constituents why we've
made a certain
recommendation.
So how does this really work?
In the original
way that we did
these things, we took a lot of
our training data.
We built these machine
learning process,
and we learned the functions,
and we would then just
give a recommendation
to our physicians.
For example,
we we think that patient x y z
should take drug,
one two three,
and that would be
the outcome thing.
But the we couldn't
explain why
we made that recommendation
other than well,
it's based on
analyzing hundreds
of millions of
patient records.
Right? What we're trying to do
is get to this
new era where we
put an explainable graph model
in between
the machine learning
process and then and then
explanation interface.
And that means that
as we traverse this,
we're building a document,
and we can explain why.
We can tell you how what our
confidence levels.
We can help indent
engender that trust,
and we can even give links to
references to papers,
that justify this
and the datasets
and to reports. Right?
So that's why we are really
focusing on bringing
this holistic
approach to having
AI and machine
learning feed our graph,
and that graph has data and
concepts that everybody can
understand and we can build
explanations on.
So, couple of things
just to mention,
cautionary tales here.
The first is,
that our brains are
kind of like graphs.
Brains typically have about,
eighty four billion neurons,
but these neurons
are also much
more highly connected.
Typically, about ten thousand
connections per neuron,
whereas our knowledge graphs
that we're building,
at scale almost consistently
have a five point
two relationships
per vertex. So a much,
much lower degree,
a much smaller number
of connections
between, vertex.
So we want you to
be very cautious
about using these metaphors
because the brain
structure is,
in fact, very different.
Another story I wanted to,
relate is this idea that when
people say, well,
we have to use AI and deep
learning and machine learning
for everything,
we want to make sure that you
realize that just
like our eyes
see only superficial patterns
but may not
understand things,
that's really where a lot of
machine learning for images,
really are today.
And one of the,
things I do in my,
student classes where we're
teaching AI to,
junior high and high
school students,
is we're taking these three d
printed models of
a turtle, for example,
and we just literally
tape a wood
grain texture, to
the top of that,
and we put it in front of our
cameras that are doing,
object recognition,
and they think it's
a rifle. Right?
Because the training sets were
never really based on turtles
that had wood grain. Right?
It's something that they're
really focusing on the texture
of something, but not on its
shape and not on
its structure.
So, it's really important to
understand that current AI is
not really at
the high level of
cognition. It doesn't really
understand these
things and shape.
It's not building
a scene graph
of these things.
It's really focusing
on patterns
and that low level
pattern recognition.
And so now one
of the things we
wanna just mention
is that when
we're looking for algorithms
that work against graphs,
one of the tragedies that in
the past we haven't done is we
haven't taken the structure of
the graph into account when
we're building features for
machine learning.
And one of
the summaries I have
is structure is
the new gold in
data mining. So
we're now taking
algorithms like
graph convolutional
neural networks.
There's a whole
whole presentations
we have on that,
separate topic,
graph embeddings.
And we're finding
that structure
helps us find deep insights.
There's a lot of interesting
things that came
out from this,
twenty eighteen paper,
and, from Google,
and it really shows you how
Google is really
pushing the boundaries
of using labeled
property graphs,
in their system, to
find deep insights,
not just for search,
but for other areas
in, Google Health.
So, don't I'm not think don't
think I'm gonna go into this,
in too much detail,
just to say that we're,
treating graph data.
Think of it as, an image
as a Cartesian,
plane where, there's Euclidean
geometries where points are
consistently distance,
and we're just throwing out
the the assumption that points
have to be equidistance.
Every relationship
in our graph
is a different structure.
These are called
non Euclidean,
geometries, and we're still,
using the same kind
of neural networks,
to do classification
and things
like that on those graphs.
So these are all coming out of
those papers. And,
one thing about this is we can
build also hybrid labors,
lay layers where we classify
things by images and then find
these embeddings,
make sure those embeddings are
structured, and
then we can pack
process those in parallel.
So, to summarize here,
we're really going
through this
era of computing
where we started
out with procedural rules,
where we wrote if then else
statements as rules,
and we wrote those
on in programs
that acts access the data,
and we came up
with answers and
explanations. The
machine learning
era said, let's still
ask questions,
but let's pair the data and
the questions
together and predict
the results. But we had to go
through ten million weights,
and there's no explainability
when we just use pure
machine learning.
What we're really
trying to move
towards is this graph era.
The graph era is where we're
still using both
knowledge graph
and machine learning together
so that we can
combine knowledge
and answers, but also create
explanations for
our stakeholders.
Not everybody needs,
explanations and trust,
but in health
care and a lot of
other areas where
we're recommending
things to customers, those,
answers are really important.
So those are some
of the stories.
Couple things about
storytelling,
it's testable. We encourage
everybody to present stories,
face to face, gauge
people's reactions.
That's harder to do
in the COVID era,
but, we're,
definitely wanna
make sure that
you test these stories,
get back to people about two
weeks after, and then see if
they can answer
the questions back.
What was this thing
about graph?
How is it different
from relational?
What was that,
neighborhood walk story?
Could you remember
that story?
If they can't remember it two
weeks later, you
need to go back
and work on your stories.
Storytelling is testable,
and we encourage
you to continue
to test that until you have
stories in your context
of your groups,
that do that. Alright.
So I think I'm just
about at, time here.
I just wanna encourage people
to reach out to me if you have
any questions. I
blog on, Medium.
Share your stories.
And there are just a couple
other things.
And, just to
remember that when
we think about graphs,
think system
thinking is really,
an important part
of that process,
that we want to make sure that
we understand that graphs help
you think about different ways
of solving problems and
interconnecting these parts.
We feel that connected data is
the key to mother
modern data science,
and our data scientists all
agree to that. We want you to
start to thinking
of your projects
not as silos, but inter
interconnected graphs.
We hope that you
understand that
connecting data adds value.
And trying to put a a a a cost
on that is difficult because
it's based on your insights.
So understanding what is easy
to measure and what is hard to
measure doesn't
mean you shouldn't
try to measure
those insights.
It means that you should start
to put abstract
processes in place.
Remember, these
laws are absolutely
gonna be prevalent forever.
You're not gonna change.
And, we hope that you,
have some good
inspiring questions
to ask. Okay.
Shush, should we
open it up for
questions? Great.
Thanks, Dan.
Fantastic talk.
Great feedback on the chat.
Question from Jacob.
Expanding on
the idea of telling
stories to promote graph use,
how do you
facilitate conversations
around schema
development? Yeah.
Great question.
Schema development is,
is really kind of,
one of the the things
that shows
the maturity of your,
graph analytics team.
One of the things that I have
run across over and over again
is that when people often,
are starting out,
they model the graphs
like relational.
They attempt to
minimize join,
operations, and
they don't really
try to find
the connections that
model the truth.
And so, it's really important
that you try to unlearn those
the habits that
you you have and,
that we,
hope that everything
that a lot
of the users can
go beyond that
and really model
the detailed,
relationships, as
they should be.
I'll read this
question from Jean.
So do you think application
developers must
create applications
interacting
directly with Graph
DBs instead of
relational DBs,
or should applications still
manage relational
data assuming
that data are later
transformed,
exposed, or dropped
into a graph
database? Great question.
So I think it all
depends on, context,
of course.
It's kind of a cop out to say
it depends, but that's really
the first answer.
But the way I would
refine that is,
when you are
creating integrated
views of your enterprise,
specifically all
the touch points
from your customers,
the the relational databases
just don't scale.
So if you're focusing on,
those integrated
analytical views,
it should always
be in a graph.
If, on the other hand,
your focus is
compatibility with
existing relational systems,
then you're gonna
make a different
set of choices,
and that sub
choice is gonna be
based on how much
data you have.
Is it third party?
Do you have the ability
to change it?
There are
organizations that are
using graph databases for full
ACID transaction stores,
single source of truth,
things like that.
But, that's a different
set of patterns.
So I think the answer really
depends on
the context and which
patterns are
appropriate for you
to prove.
As usual, the answers are
dependent on the context.
That's kind of
the the big rule
about graphs and reality.
So so we have another
question here.
Jacob, there's a lot of people
that can weigh in on this,
but he's asking if there are
tools for schema development.
Oh, tools for schema
development.
Yeah. Most graph
databases have,
graph modeling tools.
There are a handful,
let's say,
about a dozen of other third
party tools, that you can do,
modeling with.
And, a lot of them,
are very graphical oriented.
They use web browsers.
So, I'd say, yes.
There is a a group
of tools, and,
I should mention there's,
some people that
keep a list of
all those tools.
So, and I'll if you get if you
give me a a time
to think of that,
I will try to,
remember some of
the people that
are keeping a list
of those tools.
But, yes, there
are other tools,
that you can use to
do graph modeling,
and then, they generate the,
data definition language for
those graphs, for Cypher or,
type of graph or whatever your
graph databases are.
I will definitely
follow-up with
you about that list, Dan.
That's fantastic news.
And we have another question
from a Taymor on
storytelling.
Along with your
blog, Dan's blog,
what resources
do you recommend
for learning and practicing
storytellers storytelling,
especially for
decision makers?
Great great question.
That, there is a really good
book by Alan Alda,
on the processes.
He's gone to help scientists
communicate with
their constituents
better. And it's
something like
the title of If
I Had This Look
in My Face, Would
I Understand You?
Something like that.
And I'll I'll get the link to
that book too.
It's a very short
paperback book.
It's not a huge, read,
but it really does go
into some of the,
brain science
behind storytelling
and how you can use emotion to
get people to remember.
And Alan Alda is
the champion of comedy,
of course. And,
one of the ways that he is
teaching then,
people to do this
is by improv. Right?
You go to improv,
and you get people to laugh.
And if you're talking
about a topic
and you can trigger laughter,
you're gonna get
them to remember
those things.
So, those are,
very good books.
Just, I'll I I can
give you a hand
handful of other books that I
found useful in the past too,
and we can post that,
on our resource
site later on.
Great. Yeah. And
and I can share
that in the Slack as well.
And I can attest the power of
laughter and Dan's
storytelling.
We had a knowledge espresso
about a month ago, I think,
and I still remember
the the the,
story that you used to tell us
about graph embeddings,
which was what was
it, Ellie? Tell me.
It was yeah. Mowgli
facing Right.
An orange cat, and we weren't
sure if it was a house
cat or a tiger,
and I laugh because
I have an orange
cat. So Right.
So we made an emotional
connection,
and that's. Moment.
And now here's the hard part.
Can you tell me
what was the take
home point about
that story? Yes.
I can, actually,
but only because I think about
this all the time and because
you're such a great
storyteller.
So the idea here was how do we
actually help
the computer, the AI,
recognize
the difference between
the threat, which
would be the tiger
and the house cat,
and that was really the point
of graph embeddings
as a solution.
It's a it's a time
it's a speed thing.
Right? If you if you can't
recognize that tiger
in a a fraction
of a second and
and turn around
and run back to the safety of
the village, your life will be
in danger. And it's the same
thing as if you're
running an ecommerce
site and you're recommending
flamethrowers to
people that are
trying to shop for
wedding gifts,
or or baby gifts.
Your your
ecommerce recommendation
is gonna be endangering your
existence too.
So you're right.
It's all about real
time recommendation,
and, I'm glad you
remembered that.
So the story was
successful, I guess.
Oh, absolutely. Yes.
The the entire
coffee chat was,
and I'll share the link
to that as well.
So I think we're
a little bit past time,
but, Dan, wonderful
presentation.
It's so great to
see you again.